[موسيقى]
تجربه الزئر في 7 pintings بتبتدي من اول
ما بيدخل او ما بيدخل بيلاقي طاوله حيه في
رسومات بتترسم عليها
وبيلاقي لوحه الموناليزا جنب الطاوله
وبدل ما يلاقي اطباق بيلاقي اللي بيسموه
او لوحه الرسم
وبيلاقي المشروب بتاعه محطوط على زي
الادوات الفنيه وهو اللي بيعمل المشروب
بنفسه
ببتدي بحكي القصه وقصه ان ليوناردو دافنشي
روحوا استحوذت على طاوله وطلع كلم الزائر
واتكلم مع الموناليزا وقال لها انه عنده
فكره جديده طبعا بيبقى فيه زي حوار بينه
وبين الموناليزا وهو بيقول لها ان انا
قريت في كتب ان في قبائل الافريقيه
بيؤمنوا ان انت لو اكلت قلب الاسد هتبقى
شجاعه
فانا فكرت ان انا اخلي الناس كلها تاكل
الفن تاكل اللوحات الفنيه وبالتالي العالم
كله يبقى فنانين ويبقى عالم احلى بكتير
[موسيقى]
حلوه بيعمل شف صغير بيعمل زي طهي صغير
اسمه عمر ويبتدي الطاهي الصغير بالتعاون
مع ليوناردو دافنشي يقدم للزائر سبعه من
اعظم لوحات العالم
[موسيقى]
نحاول ان احنا نخلي الزائر يتذوق اللوحات
فعلا ان هو ازاي اننا نستخدم الطعام كاداه
فن بدل ما ندي درس فن او درس تاريخ نخلي
الناس تحس باللوحه تحس بالفنان وكل وجبه
لها طابع مختلف تماما وموسيقى ومؤثرات
الصوتيه والمسموعه مختلفه من واحده
للتانيه تتناسب مع اللوحه اللي احنا
بنقدمها
[موسيقى]
كل الناس قالت كلمه وهو ده كان هدفنا احنا
بنطلع الطفل اللي جوانا بيكاس سؤال انا
قعدت سنين عديده بتعلم ارسم زي عظماء الفن
لكن قعدت عمري كله بحاول اتعلم ارسم زي
الطفل فاحنا اولى بنيجي نقول للناس اي
حاجه اتعلمتها على
المطاعم الرقيه احنا عايزينك تطلع الفنان
والطفل اللي جواك
[موسيقى]